ma ya estaban casados
yo espero mi turno mi última curva bebo
sin olvidar de nuevo para olvidarme
quiero guardar tu imagen como un cohete
en las nubes bueno salió al mismo tiempo
que stefan por la salida de urgencia
jean-pierre lee las estrofas de la
canción que el músico capta en buggy
dedico a stefan su hijo asesinado con 39
años en la sala de conciertos bataclán 2
el rockero fue de los últimos en verlo
con vida conocí a este fan director de
un popular restaurante parisino mientras
subían de los terroristas aunque
corrieron distinta suerte la letra de la
canción está en el libro que yo en pie
escribió para encontrar respuestas a la
tragedia pero también para su nieto el
hijo de este fan que hoy tiene 10 años
sabe que su padre murió pero no sabe
nada es muy muy complicado de explicar
pero si un día él pone preguntas tendrá
un documento que le permitirá entender
el contexto no sin dudarlo en un primer
momento rompiera ha decidido hacerse
parte en este proceso fuera de lo común
en que comparecen 14 acusados sin
embargo aún no sabe si tendrá la fuerza
para entregar su testimonio en la
audiencia
aunque les den 10 20 30 no va a cambiar
nuestro cotidiano ni hará volver a
nuestro hijo
pero otra cosa importante sale de la
instrucción eso va a dejar en evidencia
a los entretelones de esta masacre
quienes fueron las personas que en el
extranjero manipularon y desarrollar una
ideología mortífera de canal hasta que
el zoom y de dispersión quiere conseguir
y creo que eso está bien y es
interesante porque permitirá entender lo
que pasó y evitar que se reproduzca me
feel the beat y que seas joven mismo la
ciudad de niza también víctima de un
terrible atentado en el 2016 en este
mismo paseo donde conversamos con rapear
es su hogar una parte del año allí ha
participado en grupos de palabras junto
a otras víctimas esos encuentros y el
libro le permiten no sin culpa seguir de
pie